or merci d'être avec nous le chef de la
diplomatie chinoise a rencontré emmanuel
macron et son homologue français jean
yves le drian
que peut-on retenir de ces entretiens je
prends déjà qu'il faut en retenir que
c'est un dialogue orochi et chinois
puisque la visite en france s'inscrit
dans une série de cinq pays ont dit à
commencer par l'italie
les terminera à l'allemagne outre la
france il ya également les pays-bas et
la norvège
alors j'ai toujours en qu'il s'agit
d'une opération séduction
certains commentateurs parler de ta
match franck chose qui a manqué à dire
essayer de limiter les dégâts
on sait que la relation entre la chine
et le reste du monde est devenue tendue
mais au niveau européen il ya de grands
enjeux qui sont sur la balance en
particulier la nécessité de signer un
accord d'investissement d'un accord sur
les investissements entre l'union
européenne d'une part et la chine
d'autre part qui devait avoir lieu à
l'automne dont il est question que ce
soit peut-être en hiver mais en tout cas
rien n'est sûr et la chine essaie
d'avoir une accélération on voir un
succès avant l'élection américaine
réalité et essaie de mettre en place cet
accord est vraiment remis la chine sur
les investissements et l'eau ou en gi le
ministre des affaires étrangères fait la
tournée des capitales qui compte sur ce
dossier alors vous dites c'est une
opération à séduction pour limiter les
dégâts
c'est clairement une tentative de
rapprochement après les tensions liées à
la propagation du comité 19 et les
accusations sur les mensonges présumé de
la chine sur la gravité de l'épidémie
non je crois que ça n'est pas lié
nécessairement hauts commis de 19
lorsque l'ensemble de la relation
s'est dégradée ou en tout cas est en
risque après les coups de boutoir
américain qui ne porte pas que sur le
côté 19 mai qui porte sur les
technologies de l'information qui porte
sur le commerce qui maintenant pas sur
l'investissement si vous voulez c'est
intéressant de comparer cette visite
aujourd'hui ces jours-ci par le ministre
des affaires étrangères à la visite le
président xi jinping avait mené en mars
de l'an dernier en mars de l'an dernier
l'objectif de la visite du président et
essai était d'essayer de rallier un
certain nombre de pays
un d'initiative des routes de la soie
d'ailleurs à l'époque l'italie avec un
autre gouvernement
certes avait signé vous voulez rejoindre
cette initiative donc si vous voulez 18
mois plus tard on a des objectifs qui
sont nettement moins ambitieux et qui
montre bien qu'il ya une charité rue
lunel l'attestation d'une dégradation
générale de la relation sous les effets
largement du dépotoir américains dont
l'objectif de cette mission c'est de
limiter de marque un arrêt à cette
nombre des réclamations est également
j'allais dire de mobiliser l'europe pour
que l'europe ait sa propre politique et
l'europe ne suivent pas nécessairement
la politique insuffler ou influencés par
les états unis
et c'est possible ça c'est possible dans
des chalets dans une fenêtre de tir qui
est aujourd'hui de plus en plus étroite
pour deux raisons d'abord parce que on
est proche de l'élection américaine et
tout le monde est un peu attentiste
l'europe également ici au mois de
novembre ça va être très difficile
parvenir à des accords héritage qui
engage l'avenir c'est à dire que dans
les 2 mois d'incertitude viennent les
gouvernements sont hésitants à prendre
des décisions qui les engage sur raison
d'une décennie par ailleurs il ya une
réflexion stratégique en europe et dans
l'union européenne
on voit bien le même si un johansson
était lui aux etats-unis aujourd'hui un
déplacement de la relation chine et les
états unis qui implique etc et aussi de
l'occaz
ont l'opportunité pour l'union
européenne et pour les pays européens de
redéfinir leurs stratégies plus
largement
là on le peut vite vous c'est que nous
sommes dans une crise économique suite
au vide et que nombreux pour deux pays
de l'union européenne ont envie de
saisir cet os profité pour faire une
relance et aux les années noires modèle
ben oui c'est possible mais j'allais
dire une influence de la chine chez
décision il va être beaucoup plus
nationale souveraine française allemande
je le disais mais aussi italiennes ou
d'y visiter pays bar on sait le pays bas
et des branchements un rôle déterminant
dans les négociations sur la relance ac
de relance européen sur la relance des
européennes eh bien tous ces pays ont
envie d'aller de l'avant
à lire très auto-centrée et on ne tarde
pas nécessairement dans une rue pour la
relation avec la chine n'est pas
l'élément le plus déterminant vite
admission diplomatiquement difficile
alors aragon aux mines 19 beaucoup de
pays on parlait de recentrage famille
est l'un des grands thèmes de cette
mission demande y est de préserver les
chaînes de valeur et redévelopper la
confiance et la coordination économique
entre les deux parties pour que les
chaînes de valeur ne se relocalise
rapidement si vous tes joël ruet la
situation politique à hong kong a
souvent été un sujet de différend entre
chinois et est européens à ce que le
sujet a pu être évoqué selon vous par
emmanuel macron jean yves le drian face
à bangui et qu'est ce qui a pu se dire
d'après vous alors la france et la chine
ghiz toutes les deux être dans une
relation globale une discussion globale
donc les évident que tous les sujets ont
été abordés tous les sujets ont été
discutés et où on y prend la partie la
plus longue de sa mission pour la frappe
bonjour donc l'ensemble des choses à
discuter mais il est à remarquer que au
moment où on se parle il ya toujours pas
de compte rendu qui a été mise en ligne
par des visées par le quai d'orsay
donc je crois qu'une partie des
discussions vont rester j'avais dire
confidentielles
sur la question de hong kong je prends
que la france mais d'autres pays
européens également ont une position de
realpolitik
c'est à dire que dans un monde très
troublée aujourd'hui avec toutes les
incertitudes que j'ai déjà décrite
chacun des pays se concentre sur ce qui
est à ce qu'elle estime être un
fondamental pour elle pour sa relance
pour un nouveau modèle est donc cette
sorte de la hiérarchisation est longue
et discuter après nombreux néo ce sujet
je l aurais merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste au cnrs et président du think
tank veut bridge tank